con 39 años de vida y 10 en el oficio de
constructor a sonia quispe es un ejemplo
del avance femenino en un sector ocupado
en su mayoría por hombres dejó de ser
una peón a para convertirse en una
contratista ahora trabaja en la obra
fina de un futuro restaurante en un
nuevo centro comercial de la paz el
trabajo que ya aquí ha sido poner
cielorraso de drywall el puesto cerámica
y ahora estoy culminando con lo que es
la cultura no es habitual en el mundo de
la albañilería pero sonia es la maestra
de la obra y su esposo su orgulloso
ayudante la arquitecta que la supervisa
valora su empoderamiento como mujer
trabajadora calificada las mujeres no
desempeñaban estos roles y ahora podemos
verlos cotidianamente haciendo este tipo
de trabajo incluso con un toque especial
con uno es el de sol para sonia lo más
difícil como albañil ha sido el esfuerzo
físico y haber sufrido lesiones a causa
de accidentes
me ha costado me sigue costando porque
hay momentos hay cosas pesadas que se
alza así y yo a veces trabajo con mi
esposo para que me ayude no porque
lastimosamente estoy un poco mal también
de los riñones y tuve caídas de una
escalera entonces me lastimaron los
hombros
las mujeres dedicadas a la construcción
generalmente son contratadas para barrer
mover tierra o carretillas y los
trabajos mejor pagados son para los
hombres para ayudar a cambiar esa
realidad sonia ha fundado con otras
mujeres su propia empresa si vamos a
estar operativas
pero si vamos a estar constantes estos
pueden suscribir más
sonia y estas mujeres constructoras aún
tienen muchos desafíos por delante pero
están unidas para afrontarlos